MOB.
EVER.
THE MATTER WHAT.
TAMMY BRUCE IS A RADIO HOST AND
PRESIDENT OF WOMEN'S -- I'VE
NEVER SAID THIS.
I WORKED AT FOX FOR TEN YEARS.
I'VE NEVER SAID THIS ON THE AIR,
BUT I THOUGHT IT THE WHOLE TIME.
YOU'VE GOT ONE CHANNEL THAT
DISAGREES WITH ALL THE OTHER
CHANNELS, AND ISLANDS OF DISSENT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE SEA OF
SAMENESS, AND THAT'S TOO MUCH
FOR THEM.
I WONDER IF WE'VE BEEN LYING TO
OURSELVES WITH THE EXTENT THEY
LIKE TO SHUT THIS CHANNEL DOWN.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
WHAT YOU DESCRIBE IN YOUR
COMMENTARY IS TOTALITARIANISM.
IT'S PART OF THE REASON WHY I
LEFT THE LEFT, MY FIRST BOOK IS
THE NEW THOUGHT POLICE, WARNING
ABOUT THIS TRAJECTORY,
THE COMPLAINING ABOUT WORDS,
OPINIONS, WAS BEYOND THE
CONVERSATIONS WE NORMALLY HAVE.
IT WAS BEING DESIGNED AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WAS BEING DESIGNED
TO BE ABLE TO DESTROY PEOPLE.
I LOVE COMING ON THE SHOW.
I AM HONORED TO BE PART OF
FOX NEWS WHAT YOU DISCUSSED.
I'VE NEVER BEEN TOLD WHAT TO
SAY, I'VE NEVER BEEN TOLD WHAT
NOT TO SAY, I'VE NEVER BEEN
REMOVED BECAUSE OF A PRESUMPTION
OF WHAT MY OPINION WILL BE, YOU
AND I WILL DISAGREE HAVE
DISAGREED ON MANY ISSUES.
WE'LL DISAPPOINT EACH OTHER ON
OCCASIONS.
BUT WHAT WE EMBODY HERE IS THAT
WE CARE ABOUT EACH OTHER, WE
WILL HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS,
AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE THEM
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE AND HAVE THAT
EXCHANGE.
WHAT'S MANIFESTING HERE IS A
DESIRE TO SHUT THAT DOWN ACROSS
THE BOARD AND IF THE LEFT THINGS
THAT IS THE MONSTER THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO CONTROL AND JUST AIM AT
US?
THEY ARE GOING TO BE VERY
SURPRISED WHEN THE MONSTER GETS
OUT AND BEGINS TO MOVE AMONGST
ALL OF THEM.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK IS A
PROBLEM FOR SOCIETY IN GENERAL
AND FOR THE LARGER EFFORT ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS BECOME A BETTER
NATION, BECOME BETTER
PEOPLE, AND EMBRACE OURSELVES.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S DIFFICULT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE MIND-SET THAT
LEADS -- YOU SEE IT ON DISPLAY
IN THE OTHER CHANNELS EVEN NOW,
TO WANT TO SHUT DOWN PEOPLE WHO
DISAGREE.
I GREW UP IN    IN A WORLD WHERE
MAGAZINES ARE IMPORTANT, YOU
HAVE THE NATIONAL REVIEW, THE
AMERICAN SPECTATOR, THE NATION,
"MOTHER JONES," VILLAGE VOICE,
SURE.
NEVER OCCURRED TO ME TO SHUT THE
OTHER SIDE DOWN.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO STOP ALL
DISSENT.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF THAT?
>> PART OF WHAT I HAD A HAND IN
AND WHAT I STILL WORK ON MAKING
UP FOR IN THESE YEARS IS THIS
DESIGN OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WE
REALLY COULDN'T ARGUE THE
DETAILS OR THE ISSUES.
WE COULDN'T REALLY PERSUADE
PEOPLE ON THE ISSUES.
AND THE WAY THEN -- OF COURSE,
IT'S NOT JUST THE AMERICAN LEFT,
BUT THE LEFT OF THE WORLD, THE
ONLY WAY THE LEFT CAN SURVIVE IS
BY SHUTTING DOWN DISSENT
LITERALLY AND ELIMINATING THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT SPEAK UP,
EVEN WITH A DIFFERENT IDEA, THE
IDEA AS YOU'VE NOTED ON THE
ISSUE OF CONFORMITY.
ANY VOICE OR ANY INDIVIDUAL THAT
IS A REMINDER THAT WE CAN
APPROACH THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND
SOMETIMES OFFEND PEOPLE AND
SOMETIMES MAKE MISTAKES IN
ISSUES WHERE THEY APOLOGIZE,
BUT THE DIFFERENCES IS THAT THE
LEFT CANNOT STAND AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THERE IS ANY CHALLENGING
BECAUSE THEY RELY ON THE
COLLECTIVE OR THEY DON'T RELY ON
IDEAS.
THEY RELY ON FEAR AND DIVISION
AND CONTROLLING PEOPLE IN THAT
FRAMEWORK.
YOU SEE IT UNFOLDING STILL IN
VENEZUELA, IN CUBA.
IT'S THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION.
IT'S THE ANTITHESIS TO
INDIVIDUAL PERSONAL FREEDOM
WHICH INVOLVES THE NEED TO HAVE
LARGER CONVERSATIONS, TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK OUR MINDS WITHOUT FEAR
AND WITHOUT BEING BULLIED OR
THREATENED BECAUSE WE MIGHT
DEVIATE WHAT THE LEFT DEEMS TO
BE A PROPER AND IMPURE THOUGHT.
>> Tucker: ALMOST OUT OF TIME
BUT I WONDER IF YOU THINK IT'S
RIGHT THAT REPUBLICANS IN
WASHINGTON, PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
STANDING UP FOR THE OTHER SIDE,
THE OTHER VIEW, SEEM TERRIFIED
TO STRAY OUTSIDE THE LINE THAT
THEY'VE BEEN SET DOWN FOR
BY OUR
ENEMIES?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT STUFF
ON SOCIAL MEDIA, BUT THERE'S A
CONCENTRATION OF RAGE THAT VERY
OFTEN IS CONTRIVED.
IT'S MANIPULATED AND MANAGED
POLITICALLY.
AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA, IT SUDDENLY
SEEMS LIKE IT'S ORGANIC BUT IT'S
NOT.
IT FRIGHTENS POLITICIANS WHO
THINK THAT'S A REAL REFLECTION
OF REAL-LIFE.
LOOK, PEOPLE ARE GENERALLY
INVOLVED AND ENGAGED IN THE
THINGS THAT MATTERS IN OUR
LIVES.
AS A FEMINIST, IT MATTERS TO ME
HOW WE ARE ALL PRETRADE.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE FREEDOM OF THOUGHT AND
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION.
WE HAVE A ROLE IN THE AND SO THE
POLITICIANS.
THEY HAVE TO FEEL STRONG ENOUGH